hi this is me I'm an actor and I just
got home from an exhausting day at work
it's a cold rainy night and I just feel
like making my favorite home-cooked meal
and enjoying a quiet evening at home but
oh no there's nothing in the fridge now
I have to look up the recipe in my
cookbook compare the recipe to the
ingredients that are missing from the
fridge write a shopping list
drive to the supermarket through the
traffic buy food drive back home and
carry the food into the house isn't
there a delivery service of the
supermarket and they deliver the food to
my house then I would not have to drive
through rain and traffic at rush hour
and I would not have to worry about
forgetting some of the items on my list
like last week when I started to chat
with Lisa in the supermarket and I got
distracted if I can use a delivery
service my list of to deuce is much
shorter enter the meal I want to make
pick the recipe and ingredients I want
from a list of choices put the delivered
food into the fridge and enjoy making my
favorite meal great
actually I would like to apply this
method to my working tasks so this is me
at work I'm an IT operator every day I
have to go through the same steps to the
most common events that some seem to
happen multiple times a week each of
these activities are time-consuming many
times they are straightforward but
sometimes they are confusing and it's
easy to miss a step at home
once I realized my fridge was empty I
had to take seven steps to solve this
problem but like at home it is much more
efficient effective and reliable if I
can automate my steps if a subject
matter expert writes down all the steps
to solve the problem in a run book then
I know how to solve the problem if the
run book is also available from our
event list I don't need to worry about
finding the right run book and you can
achieve all of this with IBM runbook
automation
I run book could consist of script
commands manual procedures and
parameters using run books I can manage
more work and complex tasks we can
create edit and reuse run books and
share run books within our team to make
our life simpler oh here we go the food
arrived now I can make my favorite meal
many thanks for listening